ok ladies and gentlemen is happening
welcome to find the kid
Brian the count we usually do this shot
11 30 minute you know I got the neat 2 3
well it's 3:30 now and it's not here
we have special guest Josh wolf in the
house what's going to strike this [ __ ]
up yeah we can't wait on his ass no you
know what he's even coming back dude
shooting or dude there was a accident on
the 405 and the water main broke and I
had to swim like this oh yeah a water
main it kill you in triage you come in
it doesn't work on me anymore it doesn't
how long how long into it did the charm
stop stop working yeah I'd say if solid
two years are like God pork I really did
get stuck in traffic
Wow there really was a fire in his
neighborhood Wow his dog must have
really bit his sons face off I feel so
bad for him do you after two years I'm
like hold on his old age is catching up
with him cuz he's already told me I was
gonna say did you think he doubles up on
his explosion when he started repeating
like dude you've already used that one
yes [ __ ] how dare you like a brother
though otherwise I would've killed him
was always late
ah I'd say 90% of time tonight I'll tell
you sir Rob right before he kills with
show him just a tad Brian I had the at
the time at the time the biggest meaning
ever in our lives network TV Fox had a
Fox's meeting with us right and they in
to pitch were sound on my show he's
already sold but he wants to meet with
Brian and Brennan to go over the exact
pitch of the idea for the green light
there's budget there's everything this
guy's the head of Fox he's not there
anymore had a fox though they said be
there tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. I know no
problem
they everyone leaves all I get Brian go
bro I don't asked a lot from you
he goes well you're always late I went
tomorrow such a big deal for us we'd
have our own national syndicated [ __ ]
TV show dude why everything we've ever
dreamed up please don't be late he goes
dude late never what time you show 9:30
get the [ __ ] out 9:30
so what's every one of self-sabotage of
self-sabotage yeah but he takes it
you should be his picture in dictionary
like this was way wait was was or
actually his patient beams late to that
picture
username
yeah like this would be a Twitter egg
it's just like dude wait so who's
waiting at that meeting right there so
it's you it was your agents it was just
me and Brian the agent sorry I met with
him do you want just meet with the
talent so me and Brian go in so I go in
by myself and I'm like oh I told Brian
to come a little late cuz I'll covered I
cover the business aspect and I wrote
this thing mainly myself so I'll cover
it
I told me to come in so I mean you and
the guys like okay dude can I tell you
the worst the very worst meeting I had a
network so this was back my the very
first TV deal I ever got and I got
hooked up with this guy named Danny
Jacobson who at the time you know he had
written for the original Roseanne mad
about you but he was on the last legs so
when they were mentioning these credits
I'm like he seems a little old yeah
these are all old school monkeys but
they were like that but he had energies
though and a huge deal of the studio so
the studio was like look he's got a huge
deal here and this was a couple years
ago he's got a huge deal here people
love him I'm like okay so I go to his
house first I go to his house and he's
got this guy who's typing on the
computer and he comes he can sit down we
were in the back his back house which
had a big screen I walked in and he was
on the big screen he was watching the
honeymooners and smoking weed and the
dude was typing it up right so it comes
to sits down he goes Josh this is clack
e and I said clack II he goes yeah yeah
I go what's his real name he goes he's
not allowed to respond to anything
besides clack e oh that's good and I was
like this is gonna be the fun thing
those were just gonna be the worst right
so the guys kind of he goes hey I'm
classy and I was like okay very classy
so we sat for probably two hours he did
not pitch anything he kept bringing a he
had two drawers one was packed full of
roll joints and the other was packed
with $100 bills no joke so anyway if he
would order food he would reach into his
and then he would smoke some wheeze and
he would give hundred dollars to cocky
he to go get food at the gate bazaar and
he was like I think we got enough in
this meeting I'll I'm gonna write a
pilot and I was like how he was like no
this that this is my process is how I
work oh wow so I'm thinking oh this is
his process he gots this yeah he's got
it what am i doing
I'm already counting money right yeah so
we go into the meeting and we're at the
network ABC there he'd they're the ones
about the show the guy comes and he you
know like he holds the script up high
he doesn't just slide it holds it up
high and drops it so it makes like a on
the desk in front of us to yourself
yeah he goes I don't [ __ ] get it at
all and I was like oh yeah and Danny was
like you got some notes he was like I
don't need this is past notes he said he
was like what I bought this are you sure
I bought this and he said who wrote this
and Danny was like what's mostly Josh is
I script high drop Tom I don't [ __ ]
get it and I was like what does that
mean you're not buying it cuz I don't
know have you ever been in those pitches
for with production companies or
networks it's just the worst idea and
there's like okay this is complete waste
of time ya know it's gonna work the
worst is when you're in those meetings
and you can see the people across the
table as you're pitching you can see
them start to drift oh do you know like
ah their eyes glaze over here you're so
polite whether your pitch and you're
like you know okay I guess here we go
once at a big exact was this big mean
they wanted me with me like gates down
he goes I don't know how he goes I don't
know how I come up with this stuff
he's I'm in bed at night I wake up I go
this is perfect for a job you always
hear me out here you watch the fights
you do it live but you record it with
your friends you guys have drinks smoke
weed maybe because watch the fights and
it's just a group of guys watching the
fights but in lifetime but recorded
recorded and I want it well I do that
already yeah yes you do I go well yeah
it's called the fight companion with
joão Roiz no he just goes he's complete
this
it's not a great I mean we've definitely
been doing that for quite some time now
and it's a huge success so did you fight
companion this last weekend's fight no
we only do if we haven't done what we're
doing one November but now like everyone
so bids between Joe myself Callen and
Eddie that's the crew everyone's so
swamped we haven't done one in forever
together you know what I did like plan
like last I was on road show on air he's
like dude are you in town this nope you
in town this nope you
nope yes there we go November I don't
get what it's a fight night but did you
um did you and I didn't Google after the
fights but after every July 4th on July
5th I always go to youtube and just I
like to watch people shoot fireworks out
of their [ __ ] there's no other
fingers off July 5th is my favorite day
to be on YouTube ok cuz there's
fireworks accidents interesting ok dude
we're going in October but ok let's do
the Rendon do you have got ok my
question is that what is it after the
fight in Vegas oh god how many fights do
you think were in the casino I didn't
hear about any large brawls oh I was
assuming there was gonna be a million
tons were there tongues he PM people
sent me the videos like I want to see
him and I what the thing is I and this I
should have made it more clear as I said
there's gonna be the Irish versus the
Russians fighting but it's more of Irish
Americans or American who are Ireland
fans who are drunk at this thing
fighting it's not all Irish people are
you know just gonna start throwing
fisticuffs and Russian people Russian
you know people flying over to Vegas
that's not what's going on what it's
just all a lot of timing event you go to
especially in that fight atmosphere it's
like testosterone it's in the area thick
and there's girls and [ __ ] their TVs
are bare just done watching two men find
each other in case right everyone thinks
they're all tough how many people in
that crowd think I got a shot in that
[ __ ] ring oh god like 80% 80% 80% or
like I could have [ __ ] I could have
[ __ ] taken on come on I'm assuming you
watch the fight or no yes yeah yeah I
was um I have to tell you first of all I
never seen Tony Ferguson fight Greek
what a bizarre monster yeah and they
both were do
Tekin moves like you know that dude
Eddie on Tekken yeah who does couple
where yeah yeah I was like is that Eddie
some wild [ __ ] you would get out as hey
you know he's entertaining yeah what if
these meta spring movies at what move is
that the hand with the just complete
freak Anthony Pettis that's what he does
you see how you made the jumping off the
wall cake famous [ __ ] great best
highlight of makes much fun absolutely
the hand kick honestly I was like man I
hope he lands one of those is freak me
that was crazy but um the amount of
blood and that was the the only thing on
your body that bleeds as much as your
forehead is your nut sack your nut sack
you've never nicked your nut sack I've
nicked my nuts and those things just
they lead forever yeah it's like through
the first time I Nick no that's I'm not
kidding I was like I'll get a little
napkin I was like what the I know and I
had a thought I'm like is this how it
ends Niagra flakes yeah is this how it
ends am i bleeding out because even like
I'll take to cheer my beer yeah I'll
take that to my nuts and it usually
everything all smooth sailing dude it's
just like blood it's a gusher it is a
but it's like if somebody struck oil
do you hear a lot of blood down there
just a sack full of blood I think it's
just the cotton because the forehead
bleeds like it must be a lot of time
fighters like there and up here around
the eyes the cheeks like there's been so
much hitting and trauma there's a lot of
scar tissue so the skin is very thin
very very thin like most of my scar
tissues in my left eye so I must left I
would always open up easier because yeah
think about the skin so thin any trauma
it's gonna rip faster than the other you
know last time I think I was on this
podcaster you were on mine we discussed
what percentage of people in the world
you could probably beat up and I went
with 99.5 yeah do you think it's lower
than that I don't know dude 99 you
should figure 50 and so I was like -
Theo about it about it I go Theo what
number are you and he goes I don't know
and I go we'll look 51% women and I feel
like you know I feel like girls who beat
yeah I feel like I could and I told him
I go look man I don't know about you but
I feel like I could get 80% of the women
a 80 seems like a number that seems
right because I'm not that 80 seems it
seems fair cuz you gotta figure there's
a lot of kids in that
like like if like if cat and seal
rocking down the hallway tones like you
have to pick one to win it would be odd
like but if we went the Asian she has
really strong legs okay and scrappy
scrappy I get scrappy from her okay so I
figured Theo out of the 51 percent women
I give him 80 percent I give me 80
percent I give him he's a little bigger
than me I give 85 percent he think it's
too high of a number yeah you got see
your numbers higher okay alright so but
men then I start to breakdown so forty
nine percent of the population is men I
mmm I think I got most dudes over the
age of 70 and most dudes under the age
of twelve
not all now there might be a some 13
there might be a unicorn to see Shaq 30
know the kids like a jacket 13 could
have [ __ ] kills and Freesat yeah in
over 70 like I still think Chuck Norris
could get me whoo oh my brother was
asked to miss we were watching this
video on worldstar so we do when we're
on the road shot the world star but he
there's a video of like a group of like
middle school ish maybe high school kids
who were attacking one grown man and
there's like eight or nine of them
beating the [ __ ] out of this grown man
just whooping is that and how bigger the
kids ah you know like 90 pounds maybe
100 but they're all like normal kids
like just backpacks theater [ __ ] out us
but like like [ __ ] them up like get
your stuff to watch come on and my
brother goes do you think I could do
that - no absolutely not absolutely but
we were wondering us how many kids you
think you would take I'm not sure here's
the deal if I'm getting beat up by a
bunch of middle school kids they're
gonna have to kill me because I can't
show my face I can't have it on video
you know if you have eight kids with
back Pat's be new I can't stop the
comedy store the next day like crazy get
out pretty bad pretty good pretty bad
yeah I think that I like I think I think
I could get for 12 year olds but I don't
think I could get eight like ones last
time you saw a high school kid cuz I
watched some high school football games
I'm a psycho on TV sometimes yeah Friday
on ESPN I'm like well that looks like da
fence line for the Dallas Cowboys kids
are [ __ ] enormous do you dude
you know they do all the steroids like
how about what the [ __ ] are they serving
go in the valley the prep school is no
Valley it's bananas do you know I
sparred my son I tell you about that I
remember you guys are sparring cuz you
and I were texting back and forth yeah
you guys decided to smart for the hell
of it well the my special is called
father of the year and in this it's this
basically one long story about when he
was 14
him challenging me to a wrestling match
in the front yard dead serious dead
serious
because I because every man at some time
looks at their father and thanks oh I
could beat the [ __ ] out of this guy for
sure right now happens to different
people different ages but everybody
looks at their dad at once like oh
[ __ ] tell me to take new fashioned
yeah take a step for me around 16 right
you've gone so that does right it for so
he was about 14 and he challenged me to
a fight so the special is about that so
I said to him wouldn't it be funny if
the end of the special when they're
running credits it's me and you sparring
right now it's hilarious
so the end credits yo first of all you
see my boy yeah he's 6-3 he's Hall reach
lanky and the first time I stepped in my
hand and I know this is not good you're
not your hands not supposed to go back
yeah when my hand went back I saw his
fist coming and this is when I knew I'm
like I'm getting old because I saw his
fist coming and my head was like get out
of the way of that
ain't working but my body was like dude
right punch her in the face right in the
face so I said to him I said hey man
take it easy
he goes I'll take it easy in the second
round oh wow how many rounds you guys
spar we did to the second two minutes or
three minutes two minutes I mean and it
was over with Wayne McCullough oh nice
and then we actually did want to box and
burn with Tony oh nice and but the
second round I started to wear out so at
about a minute and a half in the second
round I grabbed them and I whispered to
him because they're filming it yeah
because with the headgear and the
mouthpiece is exhausting like I can't
get a breath foster phobic
claustrophobic right and I've never I go
hey man
I think I might throw up and just then
he goes oh it hits me right in the
stomach
pearl oh no but it was the first time I
threw a real punch at so that this the
ending credits is you and your sons
going at it of him he just there's a
couple freeze frames and me eating
punches I had - clubber Lang him once
because I'm stronger than old old man I
picked him up and threw him into the
corner because I was like I need a break
huh and just [ __ ] oh dude but it was
wait till your son I don't know if your
son or whatever cuz your body he's gonna
be bigger than me man
you get it he's a feisty one yeah he's a
he's big and I was it it's gonna happen
like you you start to feel your oats a
little bit I'm right estimize I was 16
because it was like my senior year
everyone's taking the day off is like
ditch day and I had I missed so much
school at the time where I didn't have
any more days I'd be in trouble so I
need my parents to call out so I'm like
oh I can't ditch Utley my dad to call I
even think you'd be an issue I got you
know hi Greg good grades all-star
football lacrosse all good man so I
didn't think of it and so me my dad were
talking I just go oh yeah dad and I'm
afraid so yeah and I thought was really
cool Mike and did you snap down like and
uh tomorrow
ditch day need you call and thank you
have a good day and he goes not my
calling you got a good how BIG's your
dad I pick you dad 6-4 to 40 you know
like big dude were you at this time
I always probably six to 185 like you I
know I scoped nagging these all out yeah
yeah now with that either yeah awfully
not having miss too much school I'm not
gonna call and I know just caught
everyone's doing it like I'm gonna
graduate I'm gonna call chu gives a [ __ ]
and he was what you say gives up I don't
cuz him and I go who gives a [ __ ] and he
goes excuse me all right you know what
and my parents are divorced I'm gonna
[ __ ] it all so my mom do it no no I just
turn around hurts on small it's pretty
quiet and yeah I just and then it starts
to pick up and then he had a pen and he
[ __ ] Chuck this pen it's like stitch
in the necklace pingzhi it's the walls
like yeah let me tell you okay I was
like well look same of school won't do
that again
maybe I'll wait till my bad my bad yeah
next year do that even though I'm out of
school you know what forget it
I'm gonna come back we're gonna do the
same thing next year I just needed those
reality checks man my oldest brother I
remember the day he challenged my dad
nobody it looks oh oh he was probably 14
at the time and I was like six right and
me and my other two brothers are playing
in my room and my brother comes in and
he just stands in the doorway and he
goes I'm fighting dad today and we were
like what you're doing what and he was
like you heard me I'm fighting dad today
and he was like you guys got my back and
we didn't not gonna jump our dad but no
but but we also look if there's gonna be
a revolution you want to be on the right
side of that Jeff you know what I mean
like you don't you have to pick sides
and since this larger man was standing
in front of us at the time we got you
bro you guys ready or they we're ready
and he stood cuz she started going
there's gonna be some new rules I'm like
[ __ ] no rules yeah he was like we can
eat cereal whenever not a big like he
had us Lord of the Flies pumped up like
grabbing pictures of my dad off the wall
[ __ ] this dude so we're running outside
right he goes he's out back and go let's
go
so we go out back and my dad's sitting
in the back and he's smoking a cigar and
my brother walks out and the three of us
are behind him and he goes we're
fighting today old man and my dad goes
okay and he stands up my brother my
brother goes you do the old dance
Jessica he didn't he didn't he did the
old man noise he was like
right get out about to whoop that ass
and he gets up and my brother goes and
let me tell you something and before my
brother could say anything else my dad
kicked him in the nuts so hard [ __ ]
dropped in prison rule like a stone
prison world rules at the wolf house he
said to my brother he goes first of all
don't talk when you fight Jesus Christ
and he goes looks at the three of us he
goes you guys got anything to say and by
the way you know how I know that you
know how I knew he was gonna win cuz my
dad didn't take the cigar out of his
mouth like how confident he was he was
like [ __ ] kid I feel pretty good or
what this funny though is the stories
rich in there's people there and I go I
beat the [ __ ] out of my dad yeah yeah
yeah but I can't really time I stood up
then knock - yeah like there's someone
out there I'm sure there's a lot of
video like someone out there like Romero
begging tough dad was then went turned
17 I beat the [ __ ] oh yeah what do you
do if you the dad no I get to your ass
was dead next day like oh yeah I asked
what do you do
no I asked a guy on my show because I
used to tell this story on stage and a
guy and I asked her who else fought
their debt and one guy goes yeah I beat
him I'd be my dad I was 16 I go what
happened he throw you out and he goes
yeah he threw me out the next day and
everybody I've talked to you that one
and throw him out they throw him out
the alpha male he said you know what
[ __ ] Devine handle on your own why do
you need me
also dude if he's kicking your ass
restrike telling him to take out the
trash she's gonna be like eat dicks man
you take out the trash like fair point
paying the bills no what are you doing
your wife is like buddy your wife 16
year old just ragdoll your goddamn
living room what a tough move some way I
would have to wait till he went to sleep
and just get real
diabolic I'll just make a lot of excuses
would you object dude this is [ __ ]
you know I wasn't ready and then just
catch him off guard yeah when he some
time now yeah dude I I don't think that
I would have been able to handle it if
my son had beat me and if he had been
smarter he could have beat me well if he
was training on the side like doing
jujitsu and bike box there over there
some [ __ ] and then you go - you know I
do let's do this thing just beats the
[ __ ] out of you it would have been a
great story yeah I don't think it would
have been great for the house
that's a hilarious concept because
you're in your special it's all about
this and at the end we can see it yeah
yeah this special is basically tell
people you smashed on my website
comedian Josh wolf calm but like if you
like storytelling it there's no politics
I hope you're not watching this special
to learn anything it's not that kind of
special o you and if you like
storytelling it's basically one long
story from beginning in I start an end
on the same story it's it's just weird
irreverent stories about my family and
kids and it says it hour-long 16-hour
yeah man I'm super proud of this super
super super super proud looked at that I
had handsome mother fun look at that
it's really hard [ __ ] you're growing a
boss the next week brother oh I can't
wait oh yeah that's my favorite Club in
Boston it's a good now we were talking
earlier and I asked you if you had
surgery you had surgery yes on what I
had surgery on my hand my nose and my
ears and my eyes your ears what did they
have to do to it they're supposed to fix
it because if I'm it was so big he was
like oh don't worry I'll take care of
this and it made it way worse and then I
have this tortellini on my own oh yeah
this isn't about me you had surgery what
did you were you nervous going under
[ __ ] yeah I hate the hospitals
I hate when my when my girls pregnant
like I like the hospital I got how long
have to be here like I get it's just as
a former athlete like there's nothing
worse man there's nothing worse I like
PTSD when I walk in the hospitals well I
just like you heard so many horror
stories about the anesthesia that like
you can get tricky and they versus the
depend where you're at I was at my son's
born in Hollywood press 14 they sucked
there's this Asian nurse I don't know
what Asian Korean or Japanese usually
Filipino Filipino you know this [ __ ]
would come in she was so rough with my
son everyone just putting up with it cuz
I had to still work and I saw and she
like take kid put him down and then my
girls like oh my gosh I don't worry it's
just you're not used to babies and so
everyone I kind of kept quiet and she
came back she was rough again I like
someone need to say something this [ __ ]
like no she said it's Norma like I'm
telling you that ain't normal
I'm going around the other rooms
these other nurses aren't that rough
with baby yeah so she came in and
finalized all right well hold on
you need crit that's when I got a kid
like that I'm gonna [ __ ] how long you
been doing this you need to chill the
[ __ ] out
she looked at me and then turn around
left and someone else came in some white
girl came in dude
the nurses at the hospital you realize
that like where did you get your
training because some dude especially
the night shift there was a dude who I
was like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] I have ever I had to pee I
just had my appendix out and I had to
pee you know they give you that plastic
cup to pee in at night if you don't
wanna get up and I was like a horn
looking thing so I'm peeing in the cup
and I got a little pee I spent a little
pee on my underwear when I was taking
the cup out what happens that doesn't
bother me in the least bit it doesn't I
don't lie sits a lot no I know a lot I
don't like don't like even the little
drop I'll shake it forever at this hour
I should easy with it oh no no no no I
shake it for area PPN no I don't like it
shake it shake it off I do the whole
thing pretty much yeah so I take the
underwear off and I put it on the ground
and it was a hospital underwear and I
say to the nurse she comes in this young
young girl she's probably 24 and right
when she walks in I'm like I wish you
were older this sounds like the start of
[ __ ] porn huh it's not so I said to
her I go I'm gonna need some I got a
little pee on my underwear I'm gonna
need some new underwear and she looks at
me with this pity in her eyes and she
goes we need a diaper no I don't I don't
need a diaper I go I just I just I just
might get some pio myself and she goes
did this is exactly what she says she
goes did you make a mess I gotta [ __ ]
hey I didn't make a mess I'm not
cheating myself over here if you want
some mentioning stories though like my
boys wife is like the head nurse at
Presbyterian over here or not cedar
cyanide she's like the head one yeah you
talk to her I mean - we're at dinner and
should tell me some stuff like what's
yours yeah we had a guy come in he had a
full
chlorine bleach bottle in his [ __ ]
and who some damn Dyke
hook come in and clearly I was doing
some freaky [ __ ] I'm like what happened
like I was in my kitchen that's my
[ __ ] spell
I fell down and I sat on his chlorine
bleach bother like they'll hope all of
that passes whole bottle they gotta get
a detergent think she was saying the
thing she was saying like that most guys
put in there I had a frame a dead one
light bomb they had one guy come in and
it was up there for like several days
like if we don't you out you're gonna
die that's a good thing came in what was
it I forget it was like really jams out
there it was like a squirt gun
I at what point
like cuz a chlorine bottle it's not at
that's not a tiny what are you starting
with I don't know with those little the
little you know the Russian dolls I
think it's bigger and smaller look how
bad it must have been where he's like I
go to the hospital because I can't do
this bottle on my ass like because but
you went in because that's a string or
something you know what I mean you got
attached a string if you not sturdy no
friends right guys let me see this let
me get in there with a plier like I feel
like I could get pliers just yank it out
the bends easy back in the tracks up I
already do is back the tracks up yeah
I'm with you like a lot of those
problems can be solved with a mirror and
a really good friend I agree you know
what I mean just somebody who's like
this man don't fuss so you had a
appendix hooked up appendix how did you
know oh man so I'm I I was I thought I
had food poisoning because I letting in
bed and just feels kind of wheezy felt
kind of no my pet my stomach started to
really hurt and I told my wife I'm like
I'm gonna sleep out in the living room
tonight I think I might throw up a bunch
and violent the most violent but nothing
was coming up it was just dry heave but
light hurts so bad so been such a good
great so the next morning I wake up I
got 105 temperature high not great
my wife is like you gonna be okay I said
yeah I think it's just the food
poisoning you don't get a temperature
the food poisoning I didn't know that at
about 2:00 in the afternoon she comes
home and she was like you [ __ ] look
terrible we're going to hospital
we go to the hospital we walk into the
waiting room on the guy he was gonna
weigh the waiting room we'll check in
there was a dude who had [ __ ] in the
waiting room so he was sitting in one
corner fine [ __ ] like [ __ ] his Panther
he's like covered in [ __ ] he had poop in
his pants
and pee it stinks like if your kid shits
at the whole room dude is it how big was
big dude
yeah like big dude if not the load in a
nick of dog [ __ ] on our shoe it's not
game over the entire day this grown man
who was he wearing jeans court yes he
[ __ ] his jeans and here's what's crazy
my brother actually asked me did it
really smell that bad I was like hey man
[ __ ] smelled so bad somebody decided to
put it under water and it still smells
if something smells under water that's
the worst you know what I mean
how old was [ __ ] shoes pants was just so
sick like killing get up okay and this
is when you know it was like a 62 year
old man [ __ ]
so that is years of just nothing good
it's just yet runny though oh man it was
like it had a little bit it probably had
a chunk of green pepper do you know I
mean like some stuff he didn't chew that
well you just sit there in his own [ __ ]
and the rooms packed well he had cleared
an area and there were sixteen people
standing basically like Blair witching
themselves up against the wall facing oh
no they were facing the wall dude
they're had their mouths hands or
they're not other smell the horrible
walls of the hospital I walk into the
waiting room I'm already super nauseous
and I'm like hey zero chance
I'm waiting in here with the pool guy so
I'm out on Ventura Boulevard cuz I went
to Encino Hospital I'm on an adventure
Boulevard basically 105 degrees of dry
heaving on the sidewalk I come out my
wife comes gets me they get me a room
for I had forgotten how good morphine
was but the guy comes and he and he just
touches my where my appendix was with
the two fingers and he goes yeah his he
goes that hurt I go yeah yeah I think
we'll probably have to take that out and
I was like don't you want to run any
more test this dude huh just gonna do
the two finger over the skin test on
their fingertip you don't want to see an
older doctor though he was a younger guy
interesting and they're older that I
feel like they've seen it so many times
they know it's up but that's what he
said he was like look we're gonna put
you in but it feels like with the fever
and yeah yeah
guna and and then he tried to run he was
like you know you've heard the appendix
doesn't do anything I don't know about
that here's what I here's my theory I
asked him I go don't do anything he goes
no I go so it's just floating around you
don't even have it not attached to
anything he goes no what's attached to
stuff I go do the things that are it's
attached to the things did they do
things and he goes yeah and he was like
yeah everything around it does stuff I'm
because if it if it bursts right all the
bile bile so it's gonna be a filter of
some kind of bubble right I'm yeah dude
the surgery itself the weirdest part
about the surgery was I never met the
surgeon I never met the [ __ ] cylinder
until two minutes before we're going
into the room he out of nowhere he pops
up what ethnicity Armenian he pops up
any us hey and uh and I go hey and he
said he goes you look nervous I go yeah
I'm a little nervous yeah [ __ ] I'm
better yet wonder the knife and he leans
into me dude he puts his hand on my
shoulder and he goes I done million of
these and he whispers I'm the best oh I
love that for whatever that I went to
sleep I never saw here the best bit dude
he gave me I like the swagger and when
he said I'm the best he gave me a little
squeeze on my shoulder like that
oh yeah that's what I said I said I'm
gonna take a nap he goes do it I never
saw him after the surgery and I've never
talked to him
he's like the Bagger Vance of appendix
surgeon never he's the [ __ ] Kaiser so
as I see the appendix when they take it
out I should ask to see it I know what's
going on there I asked if I could keep
it why not huh no they said we don't do
that and I said it technically is mine
yeah it's not yours why don't why are
and I allowed to have it and they said
we don't give away organ so I'm like why
don't want anyone who else is fair point
but I don't want anyone else's yeah I
can't have mine that is straight by
taking it out of my house I could have
it I know but what's the problem why
can't I do I can't wonder why I but I
don't know I have no idea there where
you're gonna sell on the black market
cuz what do you can do with it I just
appeal I do with appendix you'll be like
hey you won't see my appendix
what's up Penix look like gin if I if
you came over my house and I was like I
got my appendix in a jar
let me see yeah
I'm gonna take a little look what does
it look like oh [ __ ]
where are the bodies you know the vets
car let's say they're pulling a worm out
places pull it through your bellybutton
where the hernia scar was and you know
what's crazy is there another piece it
looks like it looks like it does yeah
what
keep going chin that's me that is what
it was just a little thing yeah oh wow
look at that
that's how not was giving you problems
that's not what I've you ever been like
drawn appendix out I don't think I would
have drawn something that was closer to
that more like a libram yeah I would
have all live a little rounder that's
long and that looks like a bait that's a
swollen one you're what was what would
they say was the problem with yours
it was just infected I guess and they
had to say how that happened
no you know what it can just happen or
you can already have a like some sort of
bacteria in your body but it was not
great the drugs I don't like opiates let
make you feel shitty yeah yeah I don't
like him at all like I get a drawer full
of oxy and I don't love him
Chinn have you had any surgeries I don't
think so
well you would know what under for
something what do you mean my head got
busted open yes they sewed it back
together you busted open by what someone
hit me in the head with a wag light with
a mag light mag light what sounds like
you did they just stitched any surgeries
no I thought about it though would you
think about well like as a ving amis
girl the thing to do is to get like huge
tits cuz usually I mean I thought you
say the thing is the dude is what okay
see it's not offending some like some
people want American high yes
oh yeah that's less so I say George I
then it is Vietnamese Vietnamese girls
like the coffee shop girls have a song
about all fake tips and now they're
getting like butt injections because I'm
have you have you have the they call a
Brazilian injection where they put fat
into the ass and so it's not they're not
implants actual fat in the ass and it is
I'm not I'm not swear dad I don't be it
that yeah don't be you know don't be a
hate on that know I so but cat real
quick you're gonna get titties inside
not too well
yeah every I feel like every venom ease
girl kind of thinks of it cuz once you
get to like sixteen all your friends
start getting boob jobs in sixteen yeah
16 boo jobs well like sometimes you'll
have friends who are like 18 like I had
a cousin when she turned 18 she used her
financial aid money to get a boob job
can I tell you if I'm surprised I bet
yeah high school and girls were walking
around with fake tits I my head would
have used I felt bad for the girl who
like there's a girl who was in ninth
grade who had the impossible big titties
like they were so big and she was not
fat
she was just had some big-ass titties
and like down the hallway just everyone
was all like I just felt bad for like
you can't you kill it your titties are
everywhere dude you just know you can do
through where they can't know I hate the
idea of going under that scares me and
also like right about the time I was in
my head at like 14 I was like I want a
boob job for 19 came in and I was like
cool so but now you don't want to do it
now what was the size you would have
gone for DS maybe yeah well I was a lot
of girls a lot of Vietnamese girls get
double D's well there are like different
looks a lot of girls when I was white
called like Vietnamese Vietnamese thank
you you know like Asian import models
right what'd you say Asian import models
like the girls who go there like on top
of Civic yeah yeah like in my high
school like those girls were like the
[ __ ] so yeah a lot of girls either
wanted like the like huge net
natural-looking tits or they want the
tits not like we're huge but floated
like they didn't let them drop yeah yeah
so that was like one of two looks and
you wanted the big
Triple D I wanted like the double D's
but realistically it would have looked
ridiculous
he's glad you grew out of that face oh
hell yeah I'm so how does your man now
once you get big titties no he's an ass
guy that's gay yeah awesome legs ass
hand legs yeah I'm a hundred percent ass
all right when I was younger I was 100%
boobs really uh I've always been an ass
guy wonderbra's but then as I got older
I was like this I don't like anybody
mosquito bite titties though now in this
day and age on a team you don't have to
pick you know I'm saying yeah but if you
had like if you so if you were saying
eight-year-old boy chest with the ass
that you like or or a Filipino ass with
some big juicy titties when I say
Filipino ass you know what I'm talking
about
yeah where you like she's got a long ass
the weird looking back response I'm
definitely going to ass for sure because
again to Kats point I can always buy
titty yeah you buy an ass now
you can but he can't buy his the legs
it's drugs you can build that so you can
build that if she's on some [ __ ]
strict regimen of squatting and [ __ ]
which most hard it's not like she's
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] Gold's Gym personally
victimized right now how do you oh you
say cuz you can use the power left
yeah what was your so what was your
maximum squat I bet you it was better
than mine 240
14 what was 40 get you to 40 ass out of
here if I put 240 on a bar right now
because I haven't worked out because of
the surgery in like three weeks it you
know that feeling when you put weight on
a bar and you think oh it's good well
this could push me into the ground
that's scary some of my favorite and I
know you like the world star but some of
my favorite clips are the dudes in the
gym oh like you guys who don't know what
they're doing the ones getting [ __ ]
have you seen the CrossFit guys you get
[ __ ] up those are hilarious and
they're like so embarrassed because it's
all they're like lives or crosses one
were there the best one is where they do
that kipping and they eat [ __ ] and they
come their hands fly off or what about
have you seen the one where they do the
the wide snatch snatch and the wide
snatch and it flings them backwards yes
those are it the obviously the treadmill
ones are always good river ones are good
I like the guys who don't know what oh
my god holy [ __ ]
let me ask you this when you're in the
gym what's your biggest gym no no were
you like you're not supposed to [ __ ]
do that in the gym I don't like when
people talk to me if I'm a little work
that's like dude wait till someone's
gonna drink that we have done like yes
what are you doing that I remember I go
Jim that's put signs around the gym say
if you recognize someone do not talk to
them it's like what the [ __ ] man
especially headphones I'm in the middle
of the set do you see me sweating god
damn it
my biggest gym no no there's two of them
one and this is always for whatever
reason an asian dude with with jeans
work boots and a tank top
that'll bothered me jeans bother me
jeans work boots and a tank top but dude
I'm telling you I don't like when girls
in full makeup no I don't like that and
I don't like when you're talking on your
phone of the gym it's all phone on the
gym drives me nuts
photon gym singing a gym with your
headphones hanging oh I don't like loud
grunting or what about the dude dude
he's got a pound dumbbell but he feels
like he needs to drop it from
you can't [ __ ] rest that on the
ground bro and then obviously the big
one everyone knows is not racking your
weights like come on man yeah
yes come on but for those that Torcy
known for that for every was Romanowski
bill Romanowski he wouldn't rock and
trans same gym and he just leave all
this [ __ ] out but I heard he was like
debo a giant except [ __ ] he was
always nice to me but yeah that's the
guy I already was a giant ass it'd be
tough to do but which at this time yeah
hard to say something to him at the gym
because he probably would hole in your
chest and music you know how to track
your weight yeah you know what I'm gonna
put all that that's my workout I love
the guy also who's sure he knows exactly
what he's doing at the gym and he just
walks around and gets people take tips
dude you know what you want to do for
that bro you know you're new for your
traps bro you know you're doing you know
that's good they tribe that's good yeah
if you just arch your back here and then
get on your knees
tell you yeah the vise gammak yeah why
are you I don't remember asking for
advice and you're five four three
seventy like that's not what am I gonna
get your shape yeah because that's not
what I'm that's not what I'm going for
I had a dude follow me into the locker
room I was trying to [ __ ] so he said cuz
I was at the stall and I was in the
urinal and he came urinal next to me but
he came here and next to me naked so and
he starts talking to me and I'm like
that's another gym no no don't talk
naked bro no no I don't tell ya what we
got it but that's usually dudes over the
age of 65 my dad put his nuts in your
face and talk to you we're the photo
dead serious conversation my dad does
that Captain Morgans Yeah right in your
grill yeah why that layup them right
here's what I'm thinking for doing my
dad go casual conversation just a light
salad I'm thinking a light salad and
then some sort of protein I mean there's
not those big [ __ ] Pappas shop nuts
just hanging up the - yeah what about
the guy at the gym for sure who you've
seen the guy blow-dry his nut with a
hand dryer dry solitude you're like hey
man so first of all you're blowing your
nut juice all over the gym so I'm
comfortable myself I'll walk around
but it's okay as soon as I can get my
undies in my towel I'm grabbing it yeah
I hate guys flaunt around like dude you
have a little dick at that bro yeah why
are you brushing your teeth naked man
here you put a towel on when your
brushing your teeth I know we're all
here it's you're not at your house
you're the other side that is in in the
college football locker room there is
kids who would wear the towel we in in
five years of the University of Colorado
we never saw his dick and there's like
there's like theories on why we never
saw what were the theories well yeah I
always said it's an anteater and it's
real small yeah that was the kind of the
leading vote-getter that Bobbili dick
yeah Bobby Lee's canoe bellybuttons yep
that's the voting the kind of what we
were going for there I think that's it
for four years I was there never ever
saw students day so you get done wrap it
up
you done wrap hey hey buddy
how are you good to see you nothing
nothing we've been talking about you the
whole time start without me
hey we go for salt they brought you some
shoes come on man I got some shoes
because he gives me a hard time so I
decided to wear these are awesome
look they brought you some shoes Puma
sent you some shoes they said not be
they nots not that you why do you get
the colorful ones well I'll tell you
exactly what they said yeah they I said
because they said let me know when
you're going they said let us know when
you're going back on that pocket and I
said okay they said we really want to
give Brendan some shoes sure so and then
they said well we gotta get some shoes
to Brian and she said let me Google who
he is so she so she googled and she goes
I think I got the exact shoes well all
right let me say I think there's a home
runs you could work out in these home
runs for you dad those are nice anyway
yeah they went home runs for you they're
super what I can't wear these a chat
with him dude dad shoes those are the
ones for Humanity's right yeah you do
yep yep little meanness wheel kick in
these yeah exactly so for my wheel
memory foam I feel like they're me
comfortable is why didn't kind of throw
a wheel kick all right okay I have a
question for you
yes let's press down on that it's like a
memory foam yeah it's real good all the
way if you're known if you're not
working out in Pumas by the way
I'm all over let me ask you questions
yeah you know who jason Ellis is I sure
do
so you know he does at Ellis mania yeah
so he asked me this past year he goes
you want to come do you want to come
fight now as I got on I don't think so
would you go file and I die I fight or I
try to yeah I mean I'm not a fight but I
mean I practice and why wouldn't you do
it because there's no upside to it and
also in those sideways beer yeah money
me but I'd be embarrassed if he did yeah
but I say why I have so much respect for
fighting yeah for what guys like him
have done that to me when you when you
attempt to be an amateur at it and you
go in there and you actually take it
seriously because you are because if I'm
gonna go in there and and it's and all
those people are watching I'm gonna die
I don't want to lose going for the
fences and there's something about a 51
year old actor trying to be what he's
not that's what's embarrassed because
he's 51 yeah and it's almost like you
have nothing going on yeah you got a
train for this bread and I'm sitting
there and we're just too you know we're
at time to talk and I go hey you know I
just feel like Wayne it needs to get me
more ready for sparring he's not
teaching me angles enough and Brennan
goes what and I go he's not I just feel
like well you know one way to get
serious and break it down for me and
he's not enough and and he goes I'm with
Wayne on this and I go why he goes well
what do you want to learn I go well the
thing is I want to learn how to when I
come in I'm a and he goes wait a minute
ha ha I can't believe I'm doing it I'm
just saying for Brian at 51 I was
worried I was gonna fight whoever they
give him like what do we do but that's
what I was gonna ask him free he was
like you should pick out a comic and I
was like I don't know what comic that
Miss wise you two would be good matches
but I don't know I wouldn't fight this
guy he'd kill me he trained well fit
yeah I would he would you'd pick out
another comic
that's what he would want but I can't
think of it for me I started away to
like what's the positive and negative
the the there's way more negative
ability this way and when I when I go in
the gym and I spar a non-athlete which
is always what it is yeah just some guy
like who just once and when I hit them
so when you spar you're just moving
around but you're hitting and then
sometimes I'll hit a guy hard because he
walks in and I hit him you know by
accident I don't
I feel bad with that and I don't know
the guy I feel bad and I stop and I go
you okay and he's like oh my head or
whatever it is now I'm getting from that
you ever spar with no I'm not gonna spar
with Frank well he's been boxing too
long and also I hear he gets angry if
you're thinking Frank rellis meaning no
not me have me solder all over him not
me have you sought to test that man
[Applause]
Vitor Belfort yeah well yeah I think
you'd be surprised how many actors are
doing I don't think I'd be surprised
because he's probably do it too there's
no problem you always say that but you
never did it so well yeah if someone
needs offer me a role and they get like
Jack you want to secretly huh no no
you're not
he recently I feel like you I feel like
you want to be super lean like y'all
really lean that's gonna give me big my
body would probably eat it up and I'm
gonna be huge and jacked weight here
when I get on stage for like what though
like you need to be bigger no that's not
good you would rather you say Jack you
would rather be what - 20 - 30 - 35 -
that's hard for him and you would what
would you like to be I'd like to be just
for one day me too I mean for what would
I like my walking weight and just be you
know 365 exactly I want to be very very
thick just how do you distribute that
way two three the truth is I'd like to
be I'd like to be a six four with with
impossibly long arms and legs but a
short torso
oh good look yeah yeah and and big
fingers that rings and and big heavy
they joke about Chris D'Elia and when
and with a six for Christmas
six almost 60 no this is Paul Chryst is
my hi sir sure sir this is not sir sir
sir crystalline exactly 60 no way no yes
oh yeah no way yeah so the French plates
being that he's so enormous no he's not
what's his we could be at least six
three no way you say you think he's
taller than you no I think we're the
same watch it six three let's call him
right now see that is a great picture
[Laughter]
look at the picture they have that's his
google picture Isis he he went right
over he let it ring once and then he
cooked you over come as a call now just
gonna text I'm done this is six three
every bit about he's not shoot Christa
six three you're usually you're usually
you don't give people the extra inch and
you're giving crap Chris was taller than
six three crystal tall dude no I don't
think all linking he wears to his credit
he wears lifts and very thick soles but
he's six no he wears the live sister
Berta know but he's six - he's not six
three I promise he's not see the
difference there we're we're bust area
now how much taller six three sass
sister is he taller than Jill told Chris
but he's not that much taller than me
look draw a line right there chin go go
draw that dude are you [ __ ] how tall
are you I'm on six foot Israel I know
I'm I'm exactly with my shoes on with my
shoes off I was measured at the doctor's
now keep in mind this isn't my torso on
my neck I'm one-eighth inch off of six
feet so and people as Gordon was taller
than I thought when they meet you yes
because I'm six feet my shoes uh-huh you
put a heel on me I'm a little tiny bit
over six feet now how tom how much tall
is Chris he might be six three if you're
saying you're sick he might he say he's
wearing he's also wearing but so are you
he's gotta be sick he's gotta be three
inches taller 100% that's not just guys
guys guys why don't you give Chris 6-3
son come on hold on watch this chin I'll
talk what we really should be talking
about is whatever shirt he decided to
wear that
I lied there yeah I don't know that
that's a line leave it across sure how
scientific that yeah he's a hairline and
a head of hair all right yeah it's a so
that's all Sasso is 64 so you would
rather you would I you would like to be
6 - it's over for me so you know I think
what I would like to be 6 - um yeah I'd
like that sure I think I think you can't
you can be too tall but it's very nice
to be between 6 2 and 6 4 and because
I'll be too big like I want me to send
being 6 6 no why no yeah well if he's in
that yeah if I guess he's that but 6 6
there's that weird range where cars
coming issue at the yeah how fashions
give me that jeans yeah flying planes do
you have any tough yeah so you genuinely
like to be smaller you like where you
are highways I'm fine I'd like to be
thinner first really like firma in
January I shoot the special I'm already
lost 9 pounds so I'm trying to get down
to 230 again dude
why is that do you feel what what are
you why why do you think that you'd like
to be that he's always dieting uh he has
a nice imma dysmorphia I just I just
thought you don't want to be giant you
know there's no reason I'm this big I'm
just uh put your proportion yeah I know
I'm fine
yeah no I'm not like Oh God you know but
were you so um I'm Amy Schumer it's
crazy though because for me I've always
been like man abide would love to be
dirty bow that's a it's always growling
on the other side cuz we're we're you
know why because we walk in the room and
there are all everybody's a lot of guys
have that extra limb Hollywood around
the circle's we hang in you guys are
injured tough guys going on no but but
like it's not as tough I've also studied
karate for many many years
yeah I 30-pound there was one time in my
life I was a hundred and ninety two
pounds how much ear I know I have just
surgery got lost my get shredded though
your [ __ ] when I was 192 I was not
shredded I don't care about being and I
but I was it was the heaviest ever been
I just wanted to put on weight and see
what but I was walking upstairs it was
when I was still on Chelsea I was
walking upstairs and I got walked up two
flights of stairs and I was like I was
like oh [ __ ]
those two flights of stairs were rough
and I just could I was like this is the
last day I was done I didn't I like I
was power lifting like heavy fur and
eating like especially there's probably
seven eight months ago that's like
lifting like heavy back like I didn't
college football so like that I get to
264 I weighed less I went I remember you
came in and I saw your arm mo you came
in one time and I look at his arm looks
unusual use this giant see me like this
got Silverbacks are my way what the [ __ ]
is that I don't know even being that big
I think I said it like Mark Hunt shitty
brother 64 to 65 myself all right well I
should probably do something bad 60 I
would walk around shoving everybody for
no reason oh yeah that big I'd be up
before you know what I do I would just
stand in a doorway I would just stand
there I'm about to 54 right now last 9
to 10 pounds since then and then so bye
Jay end of January I'll be 2/3 years for
me for me and I will say this at 51 I
think I figured out a couple things been
a bit alive for over a half a century
and I will say in the past 3 months it
was because of this rice thing I changed
my diet I think I've had more energy
than I've ever had in my life
how'd you change you to it I just don't
eat like to certain things I don't eat
you know right I stopped drinking I
stopped eating red meat you know but
it's as simple as that's yeah that's
literally it and I actually don't I
don't need dairy anymore I used to eat
the [ __ ] and I've never had more energy
and I don't do any of that and and and I
Steel's greater what do you are you're
just you're doing keto for a while no I
can't do keto because I would waste away
when I need carbs yeah I need like like
those are both active when you go over
to my house I was I just cooked a whole
tray of sweet potatoes and he basically
put half a stick of butter in his and
said I and I ate it because I need that
sticky I have to but I red meat gone
dairy gone I don't go do you like red
meat I don't feel good right
like tonight I have I can't have eight
ounces of us meets wines nothing wrong
fine I get the meat sweats really no I
get that a lot bummer I don't like like
heavy carbs and pasta that doesn't make
me feel good I don't know I fit pizza
and I feel great you you can you can you
can put it down I've been with you where
you're like you know what if it [ __ ]
you'll eat pie and then you'll have
another piece of pie pushes on me he
goes like this sweetie pie and I go I
dude I see I don't have any self-control
though so you've good genetics though
I've good genetics fat I've never been
fat but I have no self-control so I know
there's some things I can't have in my
house if I buy cookies I'm not eating
them one at a time that this doesn't
happen I've put them all in my face just
so moderate I can't do oh you can
moderate with blow yeah I've done two
lines of blow no you haven't
I can't do this that's a lie nobody's
ever done two lines nobody believes me
yeah but one time I remember was in New
York was about I don't know i don't i'm
not a cocaine or two weeks but i was I
don't I know I've never been a drug guy
but the bunch of guys were doing I was
young and I was like alright and I did
two lines and I was like this [ __ ] feels
amazing you guys want to start a
business together yeah I was like
wouldn't let you do something let's go
on a yacht and everything and then I was
like then I go oh I can feel this this
is something I want to do for the rest
of the night I'm not gonna do the [ __ ]
broke yeah how do you stop and I was
like I'm gonna go take a shower
have you ever been in any drugs just
being home as long as you have oh man I
would say the only drugs the one that I
wouldn't do is heroin but no no no I
tried coke I tried I tried coke school
full-time tried a couple times because
I'm no quitter and I was like everyone
looks like they're having such a good
time you like it hated it I don't like
opiates although you know I've tried the
bike I love weed I love acid I love
ecstasy I love mushrooms I love all that
stuff you've never done cocaine no no
you there's no reason to I don't want to
lose some weight before a big guy
I'm just saying man like I don't like
uppers and ice I don't know yeah oh
you're special to be crazy I'm actually
free to do blow now that I'm you know
like ever since I was when I hit 40 I
was like my heart could guess you know
what I mean that is why I hope you know
I like I run across the street have like
a [ __ ] coffee or something whole
foods been between shooting below the
belt find the kid well today I got here
early to do this podcast and I went to
get coffee and I was like you know what
I've earned I fast all day yesterday
fast this morning and I had a nice
healthy salad for lunch I was like I
have a sweet tooth on me a coffee and
some gingerbread cookies because Whole
Foods has my favorite gingerbread
cookies so I ran over there and then I
don't wait fret the light I've crossed
the traffic where no lights good like a
dumbass cuz I'm trying to get across and
traffic is busy man I sprinted and I
almost got hit by this truck Jesus
Christ I thought [ __ ] oh these
[ __ ] gingerbread cookies were flying
there and people they would just like
this make sense that this makes sense he
died oh no oh well this speech I would
have to know dude the breeze you know
dude you know what can I be honest I
haven't I have nightmares you don't know
this but I actually have recurring your
you know you go like that when you have
thought he almost got killed in front of
me like before his fight I'm not joking
kill standing next to his Porsche we
were at Adam Corolla
ah and I and I still get I mean he went
Ceylon first of all first of all he been
training and he's ready for the fight of
his life five years ago and and and I
was like Tia and Adam Carolla promoting
the podcast and you go say it off the
tomb like like almost touched his face
and he went up and I went oh [ __ ] dude
oh and I still think about it I stood
there like oh damn that's crazy
see you tomorrow what are you gonna do
yeah just dodge the bow it was a car
flying and I weird just [ __ ] I was
it pay attention I'll see ya [ __ ] man
you could lose your face not you and I
did you like the part that not half of
your face like your tip your nose and
you know my son almost got
his toes cut off so he was working on
the show barely famous he was a PA on
the show and he was working on that show
saw and he was on the back of one of
those truck lifts and his foot was over
the side and he wasn't paying attention
and so when it locked into the top his
toes were over the side of the right so
we go and we're in the hospital and he
by the way he calls me from the ubirr
[ __ ] because I didn't want to order
an ambulance they they were to the
hospital screaming in the back of the
car right and I go ask goober guy if
this is the weirdest thing he's ever
seen and my son was like the guy goes
not even today you're seeing at YouTube
where the guy they put the guy in the
ambulance and the aliens takes off and
the guy comes just lying out I put that
at Richard see if you can find that the
guy they they would load the guy in the
ambulance in a stretcher and they both
eyeballs of Amblin and the [ __ ]
stretcher just cuz you're you know the
guy when he got into the ambulance he
was like he relaxed a little bit he was
like whew that man falls out of
ambulance it was I think it's the top
one tough one
no man falling out of ambulance and
Moscow Tunnel skill-shot yeah
to him actually that wasn't the one and
I'm sorry if you showed that that poor
man I hope he's okay there's another one
I've got blessed I didn't mean I'm not
laughing it was just it wasn't but like
you know because you assume that these
people know what they're doing do you
know what I mean when you put a lot of
doctors they're evil you go to the
dentist you go anywhere you're like I
assume you know more than me yeah and a
lot you're a narcissist where I always
think I know more than that yeah my
buddy Finn Curtin he's a real name yes
Finn green Kurt yeah great guy Wow yes I
see you are a fake made-up name my
garden if we're making a fake ID
finkerton Finn Curtin is a bad guy in in
for sure in like a mission impossible
he's a grey he is he's he's he was a guy
yeah and he he used to his job was to go
and find when when somebody would be
dead so if a guy got caught in the gears
of this dude got high he was a barker he
was one a carnival guy and he got caught
he got drunk or he was on meth or
whatever and he just got caught in the
gears of the merry-go-round but you you
they had if someone has to get him out
and he and his buddy were the ones who
would go and get the body they would tie
bodies whatever job and that's what he
would do how much somebody has to get
the bottle you want to do that well Dede
was also doing probably drugs he was
crazy yeah he had a crazy time you know
what's you know he would you before he
got sober when you apply for a job at a
carnival that's not the one you're like
my work in the Ameri ground yes but yeah
you weren't just work at Carnales right
knowing people out of know he'd find
people kill themselves all kinds of
stuff it was oh yeah it was up to him
did he like uh he he had worked for
whatever reason in a lab so he was kind
of around that stuff but I don't know if
he liked it I just I don't think he
liked it I think he was by the way I
think he at the time he was trying to
pity was doing drugs himself and he was
young and he and his buddy we're all I'm
not good around below but it'd be
innocent movie did to be interesting
when we took two guys robbed
yeah like what do they call those guys
corners or if the degrees figures out
what happened yeah yeah and then they
these guys take the body Tigers
yeah Body Snatchers like I remember when
I was looking at houses I liked this one
house terrible house great location
older house went in and they have to
tell you someone passed away they're
like yeah this this gentleman passed
away in here and that's my son say I'm
like gasps [ __ ] he's been in a while
although their houses brand-new around
but there's just old run-down house I'm
like I'm gonna buy this [ __ ] thing
and build a [ __ ] scrooge mcduck
mansion on this [ __ ] property and we
argue what happened like I and she goes
we don't know the details but then we go
into like this room where apparently
even died on that floor for it because
there's wood flooring and there's the
darkest stain of just this [ __ ] stain
man no it's clean that [ __ ] up well
clearly you know the story miles they
tried you know they tried but it but
either way I deal with that do you know
story Pete that his house is haunted
well no no they don't have to tell you
by the way they live on your last colors
what do they do
California they show my alcohol history
if a person is well I think it's if the
last daughter I don't think the hell
they go to bath it's it's if they died
in that property got on the land so my
house cuz like Indians all done Brendan
Brendan we can look do they kill a lot
of Native American I just land yes they
can't go back and bike yeah like right
right Little Joe my house gentleman was
a little crazy and he had a wife and I
think she was like a mail-order bride
and it was a the guy had the house and
he was building he built a wall in front
of the house a wall and they're like the
[ __ ] going on then he bought two
German Shepherds attack dogs and then he
had cameras and lights I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on with this guy and
this is on the property not in the house
just living in them well so so this was
the old house but they built on it yes
and they're exactly as he considered
quote unquote a remodel because they
left
I mean they left their act of semen on
all right
correct but yeah so the reason they
actually tore down and built a house
over it was because the gentleman the
neighbor noticed that the two German
shepherds were in the pool dead he had
drowned his dogs and then his wife came
out screaming and he killed himself so
there was a suicide and two dogs now he
didn't kill the wife he just killed the
dogs in himself nope and my wife its
insists that she hears dogs running
upstairs because I don't believe in
ghosts if their dog goes that would be a
good I mean if they're gonna be haunted
by some tool a master yeah you may be
haunted by scooby-doo hey what's out
with those dogs
wait you don't believe a ghost at all
sure don't do you believe do you rent in
the order of things that you think could
possibly exist Bigfoot
definitely put Yeti and Bigfoot together
hope big fit alien yes sure ghosts
aliens I'm sure there's life i'll even
100% sure how about last night i got out
of so you're saying ghost bigfoot 100%
no no but i think you know those about
ninety uh yesterday I took my son that
movie little foot I like five o'clock we
got around seven and it's dark outside
when we walk out everyone still sky with
their phone like this I go what was that
run on and we go out and I look up and I
looked like our meetings are taking over
because SpaceX Elon Musk wants something
in there but it wouldn't look like a
rocket it was this shining piercing
light there's something behind it and
everyone's like what no one knew and
then some brainiacs behind me like it's
it's SpaceX relax but at first I was
like what the [ __ ] my girl was oh my god
and she went to get our friend let's get
out of here now
I don't know what it was like but I
don't wanna be here yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's what happens to me if I'm with
family I can't yeah I know I'll figure
out when I get home but I home I'm be
able to manage whatever we manage at
home though like what's an alien I'd
rather die there than Randy's [ __ ]
ass filming this thing I don't here's I
think I'm a hundred percent YES on
ghosts oh I'm a hundred percent yeah I'm
too old for this
a hundred percent you have an experience
here's big I know not to me knock it
mock you but did you have any parent let
me say I didn't I was a hundred percent
no until I was like 40 years old so I
really started to believe and that's
only because and I'll tell you what I
believe this is gonna get a little okay
we go you ready yeah I'm not religious
guy okay sure I believe in I believe in
energy yeah you keep so and let me ask
you this when you're in a sporting arena
can you feel the energy sure when it's
positive or negative
yeah so I feel like you the energy is
actually a thing I don't think that I
can measure some energy of scientific
yeah and you can tell when somebody is
almost as bad energy I walk into a room
oh [ __ ] you feel it right away right
away so and also people so you can feel
energy so I believe everybody has their
own energy yes I believe sometimes when
you die or and you remove too quickly or
you're you're the energy itself that's
nowhere to go it stays and so not carry
it for a little bit so I do that's all I
think I think we're all made up of
energy so just because this part of your
energy isn't here anymore I don't know
why the rest can't the only yes for me
that's for me I'm with you that's a 90
percent I'm on board with most of the
only the only energy the only thing I've
ever seen was there are some people that
have a very strange magnetic quality so
and what I mean by that is that my name
is guy Eric and Eric I've to this day
I've been around again I've been a lot
of 51 years to this day I have never
seen anyone have this effect on women
ever in my life and I'm not joking
aren't you even know I'm not kidding I
call you hungry eyes all girls give him
hungry eyes I've never seen anybody he
was tall good-looking thin about 6-3
look like that hair looked like a surfer
and we were in college and I would he
could pick up any girl any time it was
crazy hey so my friend Ray had three
cats and I hated them because when you
come into the house Ray's the guy they
would guide underneath the bed and they
wouldn't come out for anyone anyone
including Ray the only one who could
entice them out under the [ __ ] the
thing was his wife when it was time to
feed them they had been traumatized or
some [ __ ] they were bullsháá
so I come in and every [ __ ] time I'd
see them running under the bed alright
whatever I'll give a [ __ ] Eric came over
I went and took a pee and I noticed it
was quiet I come back out and they and
his wife Tracy are walking on him
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
anybody who believes in Bigfoot to me
you know evidence evidence
I interviewed so I was you ever do the
Johnny dare show when you're in Kansas
City yeah so I was I was with Johnny and
he had this dude from Finding Bigfoot um
and so by the way the balls of somebody
to walk into a network and pitch a show
called finding big Rogan do that
well no Rogan did Joe Rogan questions
everything one of the things he found
was that all of these people who have do
these things that they have a they have
a financial interest in the business
Bigfoot so they so so only when wrote
though don't mean interrupted when Rogan
did that show he went ain't thinking
Bigfoot was real after he did shows like
this is complete [ __ ] let me ask you
this right and this I asked the guy this
question it was one of they was that
dude with the guy in the red shirt
answer because okay I'll try asking I
say hey just out of curiosity proactive
because we can ask all the questions I
go we eat so if Bigfoot's been around he
goes forever okay I said how come we've
never found any bones we found bones for
you go in the forest and find a deer
carcass or
we've even found woolly mammoths do you
know what he said to me he he goes like
I'm the idiot
he was everybody knows that Bigfoot bury
their own and I'm like Oh everybody
everybody know I said so everybody knows
he was yeah there's like a Bigfoot
graveyard and I was like well where is
that he was like well nobody knows where
that is I'm like wow but he said yeah
it's well-known that Bigfoot buried
there up watching this movie Dracula
untold good movie solid scary really
good movie Dracula untold really good
movie and I just went God just you know
talked to myself out loud it it'd be so
[ __ ] cool vampires are real my girl
goes I think they are no and I went like
this yeah yeah please don't share that
with that star energy to break yeah yeah
that's actually appropriate yeah I'd
have the energy now the mummies those
are real
yeah but the vampires no I think that if
you went to the Congo and what they like
I love when they find these these tribes
that have never been touched by you know
the outside but I'm sure in the Congo
there are probably animal species of
animals that we haven't seen yes crazy
stuff in the ocean well you find new
I'll tell you I have a weird fear of the
ocean you know my favorite one no
because it can kill you
yes sure rogues had lots of things that
can kill you with their face in the
ocean but also just the power of the
ocean though I'm not a great swimmer
and so I've got you know when that big
wave hits you and pushes you're scary
[ __ ] man the ocean doesn't give a [ __ ]
about whether you can swim you know you
know but so I when I used to do that
shark show on Discovery the thing that
scared the [ __ ] about me about the ocean
was the unknown right like I can't see
you know what the guy told me about
Santa Monica he goes you know if you've
been in Santa Monica up to your waist
you've been a hundred percent chance
you've been within four feet of a shark
and I was like no way he goes four feet
a hundred percent chance he goes now it
may not be a great white but there are
so many sharks out there yeah he said
within four feet and allowed down a lot
of old gray out there yeah all great are
great white yeah and this guy is
swimming
you know in the ocean and he's got his
hands talk to his waist and he's just do
this guy cuz I'm not a little steel
bossy I'm my brother jump all up in I
love the walks like you're not scared at
all nah it crossed my mind a little bit
and I'm always like you know I'm this
that guy goes it's like it happened to
me I'm always the ones like just to make
people you know you do know that the in
Santa Monica the odds of you dying from
the bite are smaller because the the
great whites in Santa Monica are
juvenile juvenile
so they said Ernie and Bert a sad one
yes hey fellas talk to this guy guy the
guy that dude the great white shark guy
and he said actually we taught AG to 20
foot or 200 feet in Santa Monica yeah he
said we tagged a 20-footer a 200 feet
all cuz I hit him with that yeah and he
goes huh well now I wouldn't say that I
said what I mean
well we just tagged a 200 a 20-footer
200 feet off the Malibu short right -
love it though man have you ever swam
with sharks before I'm one with sharks
you are one with sharks always black
tips and [ __ ] lemon that's a great white
doesn't count I eat they threw I didn't
have great wife they threw me over the
edge I don't swim well and they threw me
they said we were filming this for her
show and so they put me in a wetsuit and
flipped whatever the flippers yeah and
they said I said when are the snorkeling
lessons and the guy goes if you never
snorkel before and I said no and he goes
you're gonna have to sign this extra
waiver and I said what they ended up
tying me to a rope because I didn't I
don't swim that well and they would they
threw Chum around me that's a little
dangerous they did they threw Chum
around me why don't this Pacific Ocean
oh yeah out here San Diego so I don't
know anything about to get ratings wrong
so that's the guy said he goes we need a
good shot oh wow and I said he goes I
didn't he didn't tell me until they pull
me up in the boat he goes you know we
don't usually put Chum around people
yeah that's a bad idea but yeah but they
were like we need the Sharks to come up
and we need them come closer they were
saying that's why so many people are the
the tax for sharks are up on people
because of these shark encounters where
people want to dive with the great guy
so
the great white and the sharts think
whenever this Chum in the water
whenever see humans food because when we
dive with sharks where we Chum the
waters so then sharks going alright
humans equal food and that's why they
say the attacks are so high in Hawaii
they say sometimes you know they do the
harpoon and the underwater though the
spear hunting yeah
underwater fishing but the Sharks hear
that yeah and they automatically know
something's dead knows that and they
yeah and there you go so like it's the
perfect when you're talking about an
animal and same with alligators when
when you're talking on animal that
really hasn't changed for millions of
years right because they're the perfect
whatever like they're not to be [ __ ]
with yeah sharks just don't bite people
no agree you know it's not like a bull
shark bull sharks have you met that dude
if you guys had Paul de Gelder on your
show yes yes yes he's the guy with the
Australian Navy SEAL hood oh yeah good
dude great guy
no his show his his story is a great
dude [ __ ] crazy
I had him on that's America dude dude I
had him on my show right and so Tara
Reid was on the show also watch in that
picture oh dude his story I'm up there
his his arm
somebody's on his story he I watched the
video of the shark attacking him with
him next to me and I said doesn't this
freak you out at all and he goes not at
all the shark took his arm and leg and
let a tiger shark right bull shark bull
shark bull shark he looks pretty sweet
dude he's jacked he's Jack vegan jacked
but he said that the when they were like
pounding him back to life on his on the
on the boat because I did pull him up
and one guy one of his are still yogurt
dude that rubber hand that hand me
you're like good and that hand will
crush he can set it to like a little
shake or he can set it to our rush he's
a badass he's a good dude good dude man
in a crazy story really good dude yeah
the fact that he swam back to his
but with one arm and one leg and then
died in the boat and then the revenge
they revamp they did revenge a whole new
revamped yeah you have some current
vents chin and cat did you uh did you
guys talked already about we'll get into
that's only one here what the FC mmm-hmm
have anything no what's this great
ottoman or go ahead actor ray Donovan
was arrested for a DUI as well as child
endangerment the police had a call last
Sunday night saying that there was a car
swerving in and out of lanes in Burbank
they later found that car crashed into
two parked cars it was him in the
driver's seat and his two-year-old on
his lap with the hands on the steering
he said he was drunk
yes it had his two-year-old drive yeah
I'm not see in the back was uninstalled
as well yeah but so for everyone's okay
everyone's okay for me he does not get
it for me he doesn't get to be alone
with the kid I don't know the details
but no no I don't need I don't need the
details if the car seats not hooked up
yeah
your crash and your son on the five yeah
I don't need details well because what
what tell me what details make it better
so a kid might be super mature yeah I'll
do as drunk so he got assistance so we
have to say that at least he was he was
smart enough to know he couldn't drive
yeah so he needed some help yeah okay
yeah now when I was unwell and we drove
down to Florida to drop my brother off
at school in college and we didn't have
a lot of money and so we were basically
making one stop from Florida
Massachusetts in my dad we had to pick
what hotel we could only afford so there
were times where when my dad want to
pull over he would say I'm gonna put on
a cruise control I'm on nap put your
hand right here if you think we need to
break you see anything coming up just
tap me so I would sit right next to him
and he was on cruise control and we
would just do like 55 in the far right
hand a 12 12 difference near old it's
like way different but we'd sit there
dude
dangerous way dangerous yeah but like
back then that's crazy
back then it was all good back then you
were like I remember I remember back
then in the 80s ladies and gentlemen in
1986 I remember here in this were drunk
driving hadn't yet become what it was
yeah and I remember my buddy going dude
I get wasted with my dad and in my dad's
like you driving I'm like I don't want
to drive you drive we're both ways
because neither one of us want to kill
each other yeah lovely
so bette midler tweeted out a series of
tweets mainly one saying that women are
the n-words of the world yeah women are
the n-word of the world raping enslaved
married off worked like dumb animals
denied education and inheritance endured
the pain of and danger of child's birth
and life in silence for thousands of
years they are the most disrespected
creatures on earth
and this came prior the kavanaugh what I
think that was somebody else's quote and
she just read right can you go up a
little more to look at her second no
this another down yet the second one is
her apologize but there was one it's
actually it's the off of yeah her
controversial quote paraphrase is the
title of a song written by Beatles
member John Lennon Yoko
so I remember yeah that was she was
saying she was trying to bring it back
she was referencing that pretty a little
off and a lot of people got angry at her
for it and she went out of her way to
apologize not only for the tweet but for
all of the black women who reached out
and saying like well what are we then
because we're both black and were women
Elwood and then Jamel Hill said full
stop please stop and then Kim Kroy -
respond to her shoes yeah yeah some girl
girls I'm a hundred cent feminist this
too much I mean what's this guy got to
say focused tastic if
[Laughter]
yeah I need that what else you got yeah
so you actually tweet the cell I love
this one I love this oh you have it on
yeah yeah the video no there are several
videos the videos are great I'm a lot of
it this is funny man they're going
through the auctions just goes beep beep
you know it's freaking out you don't
have the full video there's the video
right there they're doing the auction
yeah there you go
it's from banks he's incredible he's
incredible he must he must be was he at
the auction like not is he no no it's so
fishy that's my thing yeah you don't
think he knows what stuff's up for
auction
but how does he know right when it's
sewn into power it all right at that
moment well this is the one restraining
cell so he has someone from his life
someone there that
is it almost more cool to have the
shredded one the shredder one's going
for more money is it really real yeah
but we go they panic
I like how diverse the crowd is look at
that guy the crowd so diverse look look
look I mean look at all excuse me excuse
okay we'll figure it out don't worry so
it's going for more now yeah because I
would rather have the shredded wine
right the shredded one yeah it's genius
its genius it's so crazy but that's what
my my first thought Banksy's quote was
the urge to destroy is also a creative
her that's Picasso actually I heard you
have to like inspect those things
detailed like the frame and everything
so it just feels lowly I was a little oh
no it was planned guys he knew what he
was doing but I'm saying you're saying
you're saying the auction errs knew it
was gonna happen I just it seems so
weird that it happens right when it's
sold like house it's possible that he
that they reframed it and they asked him
to reframe it very possible right well
when it's up for auction they will refer
and so somebody goes we have this an
artist brings direct especially a bank
no but the most famous artist in the
world but Michael you're not saying well
let's go here he's like old enough you
want my painting I bring it is somebody
there he has a plant there I'm sure he
hasn't remote she's you know no one
knows what Banksy looks like nothing
like right someone working for him goes
here goes just sold me is let me know
click he's astonishing it's so crazy
some badass [ __ ] yeah it's really balls
bad actually such a good artist do and
you know the person what they cut put
down one point for yeah it's for I heard
how it's going for some crazy amount of
money for now if you put down one point
for painting and then it just got
shredded do you do they offer you more
it's worth more but at that point you
don't know it's worth more of course you
just reframe it and it's like you I bet
you and be on the hook for it though
well no now my question is under like
what's 8 million dollar no [ __ ] I had
at one for yeah yeah if a fire had
started and you burned it it'd be
different but I feel like that was there
you go Ping's worth warble double of
course
you imagine making something destroying
it and then it having been worth twice
as much dissolved that was not the point
on me he's got the double shredder it's
gonna go this way now that would be
amazing if he had a double shred [ __ ]
what is anyone gonna buy one of his
picture paint pictures or paintings at
an auction yeah that's how it could
happen every time he just pops up cuz
you want money for a lot of me just pops
up and does them all around I know it's
pretty amazing so cool man what else you
guys got so you made it onto
WorldStarHipHop worldstar and say you
look like Nick Youssef do you know
what's up don't know is that yeah he's a
comic he's God you knew you know it was
up did you mate to worldstar did you
think there would be fights in the
stands or for what happened to half now
so what happened after I thought there'd
be both I thought before the events and
after the events in the stands and also
some Christian Anakin's like this did
you know about the beef that he had was
done Danis at Kapoor yeah oh yeah the
whole yeah I think is much much deep I
had a very I ever I have a point of view
on
I feel like Conor McGregor's I think
trash-talking is awesome but I think he
stooped to it a new low you know how
well I think when you attack someone's
there couple reasons I know that when
you when you attack somebody's father
and call his father a coward yeah and
you start talking about his brother and
how he got murked and also but
especially when you start talking about
his father being a coward and and you
tie him to the church any war where his
father fought then and then you talk
about how his father kisses the ass of
the president of Chechnya when you start
saying that stuff it puts his family it
can potentially put his family in danger
you know anything about the guy who
controls Chechnya and stuff it was it
was to me irresponsible and and frankly
I thought it was it was low and I
thought he was attacking and I also
think I have another thought about it
I also think that Connor as confident as
he was I think he did some research and
I think he stooped to this level because
I think he wanted it he was relying on
getting in Cubs head any way he could
because he knew that
I think he just realized he probably and
have the skill set to do it but don't
you think that's my opinion
I guess I guess what I'm saying was it
was disappointing because I've really
looked at it now and I was like like I
think his fans we kind of haven't at
least I do I go that's a little bit
different let me ask you when we went
win where's my pet mutts my taste when
let's go back way back before we were
watching sports but when Ali was calling
Joe Frazier Uncle Tom and he was calling
him a gorilla like but people Razer
never forgave him for that no never
forgave him for that ever ever ever
but do you think that stuff even though
you know Ali was just trying to sell a
fight and you know when you you heard a
lady talk later in his life that he had
a lot of respect for Frazier but he was
just trying to sell a fight it's a good
it's a good example so do you I think
that is do you think that is too far
also even though you know I was just
trying I don't know I don't know my
feeling would be that certainly today
that would be yes I don't think so any
other options to sell this fight with
could be because he's a kind of a like
they're all relied on they're all
relying on him to sell this thing what
do you talk about well khabib you're 26
and oh and really good I can wrestle
yeah you wear a furry hat you've been
doing this since you were 4 bro yeah
complete terrible night yeah go wrestle
a bear yeah yeah we own your team suck
yes you sound like Drago yeah there's
not a goal there's not a your perfect
fighter I will say this I will say this
he may have gotten mauled in that fight
but it did get to khabib and could be
made a huge losses first so in that
sense you know so for me and I was
saying to Brendan earlier where it all
ends and for me there's no there's not
even you got to drop the hammer once
you're paying public once the people who
come to watch and keep your business
afloat once they're in jeopardy you go
drop the hammer there can't be another
thing where a fight every thinks they
can jump out of the ring you don't think
that khabib ultimately that iconic
picture of him jumping with two feet
does he ultimately benefit from this or
does he ultimately there's I think he'll
get around a year to 16 months
suspension the price should have to
strip him of his Bell hey well and but I
think he's a bigger star from this yeah
good or bad the Conor haters can jump
more on the khabib train now obviously
rush it could be
huge I mean in Chechnya the head guide
that just videos of them firing off
ak-47s you know while he's winning so I
think it's both who didn't call him
apparently yeah so do you think so then
so so first of all because you had
talked about maybe could be bribes off
in the sunset so does he retire does he
come back after 60 months with the
rematch of Conor McGregor I think it
depends how long they spend khabib for
depends how much money makes on this
fight I think khabib does get prior
round a year suspension I bet you in so
Connor what mothers do to jump in the
routers already they're all [ __ ]
Connors uh Connor didn't press charges
on him so I guess but what one was a UFC
fighter in that he's like banned for
life but they're also Russian citizens
so get back in the states they're [ __ ]
right those guys are screwed but who
cares about them yeah though the other
thing is is Connor already called Dana
like today wants a rematch with khabib
but could be frightening it suspended
for a lengthy time so I bet what you see
is Connor John his coach wants like a
warm-up fight let's do a warm-up and
then fight khabib so I bet you that he
fights Nate Diaz next when is that a
warm-up fight no buts a better match
something could be but yeah not not Tony
Ferguson God you don't like Tony
Ferguson do you own a first in beats
Conor me too good fight but I I I think
I think for the paydays you're gonna
fight Nate and maybe for the 165 pound
title I'll fight Nate and then he'll
fight could be late next year
so you know the only Ferguson gets a
shot no there's D no no I think well if
he does it's after it's after you know
as Tony does Dana White secretly have
any influence over the Nevada Commission
that's a good question you know by the
way he might be able to help me get a
like a shorter sentence but here's the
problem here's what no one's talking
about the governor of Nevada was their
cage side and have to run out in the
escorted by security like like you're
good you buddy sat down and someone's
like dude those things get pretty wild
he's like what's the worst so now you're
dealing with that guys in charge that
guy's gonna have some influence on how
long you spend but also khabees not a
huge
draw like Connor is so they're usually
Vegas like dude we need this money so
let's try and figure this out you know
look at who's the second biggest draw
outside of Connor save John J if John
Jones comes back is he yeah Rose
namajunas no get out
John Brock Brock looks a little
different nowadays he's doing that you
started testing he looks a little doughy
err he's not I mean you still you still
got GSP floating around there but they
listen to answer question there's no one
no arts like a puny huge drop huge drop
you're talking from there there's
there's there's there's Conor who can do
a more than a million pay-per-views then
the next biggest is really only DC and
John if they fight each other but I'll
slide them both those guys around the
four to six hundred mark then below
there gets really shifting so he's
really like that's why that's why he
they will have proper 12 whisky on the
map that's why they're their partners
now their promotional partners that's
why the there's the video game notorious
said you know it's crazy wondering why
the the interview with Dana
after the fight right they were talking
to him about the fight and when they say
they went through the the shitty and
Gemini the ring but when he described
the fight you would he described it
almost like it was still a Conor
McGregor win he didn't mention kube's
name when he just arrived here he said
yeah I don't see I don't think as much
as a mauling as you know wrong does dia
completely annihilate I don't agree with
that I I don't think it was a complete
annihilation I would like to see the rat
rematch I thought it was like I caught
it as a dog fight I thought the first
round I would call me that with Conor
McGregor's gameplay and they said they
assume he's get taken down there what
control him don't take damage did that
it could be been enough that first round
second round you know they started you
love dice leaders especially when he
clipped them but even when he clipped
him he slipped fell back and then the
grappling was an issue their third round
cabbies exhausted Conor takes everyone's
that third round the fourth rounds where
it got super dicey yeah I didn't see it
I didn't see connect with khabib
did he actually connect all for sure oh
yeah he added there was a few yeah
that's good body shots
his kids keep his tip before I was I got
I just find it a mauling like there's no
ten eight rounds I saw it as a mauling
he took him down and just pounded on the
second round was the second round was
nasty yeah and I thought with the first
round there's no way let me let me ask
you this third round Connor
yeah I believe that that it happens
again to Connor because I don't know how
Connor solves that I don't think so I
don't think so you know why cuz I think
Connor fights again fairly soon against
Nate Diaz and stays active khabib comes
off after a long layoff he's dealing
with ring rust and then Connor and could
be but how is he going to solve the
ground and pound
nobody has how is he gonna solve that be
like you know guys like SIA but the
thing is is how did Chuck Liddell stay
on his feet for all those years he
wasn't fighting guys like a babe I'm
your time out is that is that that's
what it was so there's different chuck
is good great counter is a different
kind of wrestling your time out
different you know how did Jim Brown run
over all those white boys how did Babe
Ruth hit so many home runs off white
pitcher yeah how did it babe try hitting
off Pedro Martinez yeah yeah yeah so
that's just different athletes different
athlete different times yeah but he
would have a better shot if he was more
active not the Ringwraiths I didn't
think you look like it was enough even
look like it wasn't a prime Connery's
movement wasn't Goody's flat-footed he
seemed a little nervous to you didn't
seem nervous you didn't seem up for it
and seemed excited listen he had a
hundred million dollars in the bank it's
tough man yeah yeah that's a hundred
million in the bank and someone was like
hey tonight's the night you get punched
in the face I'd be like yeah let me
check my banking one determine who is
the best 155 in the world would be Tony
verse could be correct but again that's
not a huge moneymaker
but what do you think about that I mean
I think by the way completely amazing
pedestal [ __ ] great dude that hand
stand kick the old tech and move mercy
mess it was so good I was but I was
amazed and I had never seen Tony fight
before
beat just presses he just walks forward
the pressure he if he can do I guess
could be a cube going backwards is not a
great khabib so if he can do that and
withstand from being taken down and it's
a great matchup man
cuz long-lasting this could be how long
do I last year I'm not letting him time
I like something I'm gonna be fine
Yeah right yeah I figure you can I keep
my legs like this okay you know Dana
even mentioned that when they when they
ask them about the rematch when they
asked about the rematch they even
mentioned could be verge Toni would be
yeah they tried to make one three times
but they're not gonna get any pay for
you on that be tough no only super fans
I mean but but well by you know Russia
who knows who knows the what the kind of
rub off could be be getting after me did
they say what the pay-per-view numbers
were no Dana says training at 3.5
million but oh wow things be three-point
fun I definitely think that this maid
could be way bigger I agree that picture
the two-foot jump out of the window the
weird thing is that that might that this
is the [ __ ] irony of everything that
we live in the world today
the mistake he made of jumping with both
feet on - Dylan Danis might be the
biggest thing he could ever have done
for his career makes him a supersonic
picks 400% um what's the most they've
done what's their biggest paper you do
you have any idea other biggest is 1.6
like 5 oh so this is a tit Natan 2
versus Connor this beat that for sure
but when I would I said I don't it's
sure Spock not doing 3 million and it's
not because everyone's like oh you're a
hater no I'm not a hater kids are
stringing these days so it will it be
the most-watched UFC fighter of all time
correct well it'd be break 2 mil or 3
million papers there's no way cuz this
day and age you're getting millions of
guys streaming it that's yeah
it's not because I don't think it's a
bad man Russia's do you think the
Pacquiao Mayweather fight will do more
than 3-million know I had and I just got
a thing Pacquiao has to fight some
before he fights Floyd this was great
because it was in the prime of their
yeah this is exactly what we wanted to
see it Derrick Derrick Lewis was just
that was amazing that was just [ __ ]
at me where was that
Oh Pacquiao is gonna fight Adrien Broner
in January well what happens if he loses
he's still gonna fight me over there yes
fight Broner in order to get a shot at
may way how old is broader isn't wasn't
Broner and rocky 30 wasn't he the boxers
Antonio Tarver okay I tell you what
there's - Wow what else you got Jim
29 years old yes your honor I sent him
um this quick one diesel has a new
campaign and they're using uh wow so
different celebrities are using whatever
comments was the worst I've ever seen
online and they're putting it on their
clothing because if you do that you
disempower the word just like you know
we spoke about I feel like you man this
is listen if you're not into the known
and you wear that shirt yeah that's how
that word one down in West Hollywood and
a few bars out there you beat up oh yeah
that's tough one I don't know what's
familiar that you're doing or you get
right you wanna be gay I feel like if
you're gonna wear it well you've been if
you are gay I feel like yeah you still
better be able to you behind tough gay
guys probably whoop your ass for that
let me ask you the same question I asked
about Theo we're gonna ask you curious
now that we had discussed that Brendan
could probably beat up 99.5% of the
world yeah what do you what percentage
what do you got for Brian Cowen for me
50 you 51% of women so I'll give you
like me you can take 90% of the women
yeah what percent no ninety I'm giving
you a nine-member 61 now yeah so there's
gotta be some 23 year old women that can
write I don't know I give you I give you
free I've practiced it in one way or
another for too long
all right a lot of people don't learn
like 30 and under okay because 30 20 to
30 year old I made fun of me again but I
do get in the ring with guys who are
much younger and I do beat them up
uh-huh I do get his fame but I do but
what's the a good day what is the age
limit so because I thought oh wait let
me cuz I think anybody over to Hondo
you got some profits let me but depends
box playing you guys were did you Andre
yeah how much you what do you want on 70
will you wait a hundred so many pounds
with yeah 175 with how many folks Ari
but I've done it that's not that much
more worried but there are if you've
trained a lot yeah hey what what word
would you guys were on your jacket I
would wear we're fighter
uh he means the one that offended me out
what's up is there a bad word you'd wear
like a sweatshirt on the third leg I
think the worst thing anyone ever said
to me
online was I clicked on did hurt yeah I
clicked on one a year one of my YouTube
things came up I clicked on it because I
was trying I thought I was gonna laugh
because I thought you were Dane Cook but
it turns out you're not as funny as Dane
Cook and I was like yeah I tweeted him
back I was like hey man you know funny
games like they make fun of how old I
saw her like how how sorry I look like
the Cryptkeeper there's nothing there's
nothing not one word I'd put on jacket
that there's not too much debt of Fame
I had one guy called me I had the one
thing I remember I remember because some
my buddy wrote and MADtv was a great
launching pad for me and I saw and I was
like launching pad I was like I don't
know if I like that yeah before I could
take it out a guy goes Tigers launch
launching pad - what ya watchin factor
what obscurity
oh yeah by the way I have no problem
with Danes comedy I don't like it when
people compare me to Dane and Tosh
because we're both we're all white
people and bad company no but but but
but they all it's not comparisons in
good ways you look like a like homeless
Daniel Tosh you look like a redneck
Daniel Tosh yeah Dane Cook is [ __ ]
back I mean as far as I was watching
this dude his stand if his way better
now [ __ ] he's right he was he's on me
his stand-up now he's he's like before
he did his stand-up just on his
personality and on action he killed me I
still thought he was always so I didn't
like that before I thought he was a
great performer I didn't love him as a
comic right now I loved his step yeah I
loved his stand-up right now super
person yeah that [ __ ] the real
deal he's been doing it forever
Dane Cook is what else we got yeah great
comic this one's about you bar still
wrote about it Robbie Fox and so I saw
that MMA fighting did this time you're
the best dude I heard about this how
this are you crying so a lot of people
are saying like the people that have met
Brendon they're saying that you can love
or hate him whatever but if you've met
him you'd see how good of a person he is
and it's this guy wrote an article about
that
Larry Bork son and you want me to be let
me tell you something else about Brendon
that he won't tell you so every every
Christmas I collect money or goods from
people that I know in the entertainment
business and we always help out this
group of homeless teenage boys and the
reason I always choose the teenage boys
in the foster kid teenage boys is
because the country forgets about them
because they're not cute so they stop
getting Christmas presents and they stop
getting birthday gifts and they stop
getting attention and so every year I
reach out to a bunch of people and every
year out of the three people that
respond he's always one of them and he
always writes a check and he never says
anything about it on social media
nothing like that but he always writes a
check for these kids and
and the dude that he'd donate donated a
bunch of his [ __ ] one year which they
were more excited about because they're
right this is his stuff and so yeah good
solid dude man yeah and I don't mean to
blow your cover with that man but when
did that happen and what happened was
last week and I don't know I've never
met her yeah someone hit me up and he
was uh he posted a picture of his child
they look into it so it's [ __ ] rough
man I have a kid and yeah what if that
kid what if the guy from Ray Donovan
tweeted you he was like hey my son's
missing a couple teeth he lost some but
I can't afford medical bills what else
you guys got that's pretty amazing all
right this is just a quick one jeff
bezos so Business Insider did it
breakdown of how much he makes by the
minute second hours
how much check this up Jesus he's so
reverie 2nd 2004 and 89 buck an hour 8
million an hour eight million eight
hundred forty nine thousand he makes a
billion dollars a week that's a billion
that is a bill that's an extra no man
that no 78 billion did use a semi bill
that's you if you make 78 billion it
look like that how many years you
working at that job I know you know like
it matters anymore but well I'm still
probably do the podcast I still do
stand-up for sure you stand I do
stand-up 100% with everything else with
everything nobody I knew would have a
problem I just give money to Sony I'll
do Ilion I'm like Josh thanks for coming
hey check your bank count after is
taking that money and trying to change
the world in a better way and I know
people who know him and they were like
he might be the savior he might be the
guy who tries 70 bill gates too man Bill
Gates gives so much money and in the
right places by the way in the right
place Zuckerberg is starting to do it
too
he is tell who did it [ __ ] Steve Jobs
who
[ __ ] rough dude man I raised that boy
else is getting all me big that book is
buff oh he looks like that referee but
what's his name I know you talking about
Hercules yeah Hercule in her free his
name Oh Jack Trev
the referee arms buff NFL yes that
Hercules yeah that dudes great oh that's
not him that's the college guy I mean
this guy he's older - and he's jack dude
look at that dude with some he's a big
strong if you're if you're the ambling
guy you're probably I'd have my own glam
but I want you guys scream just [ __ ]
that's gonna make me live longer right
better correct that's your soul purple
all you want to live with I've seven
eight billion I want to live as I wanna
be Dracula figure out something so I
forever until the accident the axe is
important yeah yeah I want to be cool
yeah what else you guys get that's all
the good ones I think so nice man tell
us you're special to the special [ __ ]
this is called father of the year it is
basically one long story if you like
storytelling this is it
it starts with one story and ends in the
same story and in the premise of the
special is that we'd like happen with my
son is that every boy hits an age where
they look at their dad and they think I
could beat the [ __ ] out of this guy and
so that's how the special starts and it
takes you through cuz he said he wanted
two weeks to get ready so it takes you
through the two weeks and me talking to
my dad and him talking to me about how
we all attacked him
so it's no politics it's all and there's
no in the hope nobody came to learn
anything it's just five dollars five
dollars right and yeah man it's gonna be
an hour I'm super they didn't really put
my new merch down there huh just click
on that what happens when they shop now
oh yeah oh yeah there you go there you
go okay you guys it's your boy who made
that t-shirt one of you guys oh yeah
yeah yeah nice but listen the special
I'm so [ __ ] proud of it I'm so proud
of it because it does exactly
what I want to do it tells the stories
but it's not like long stories with no
jokes and it's against my dude I sent it
to you then get a entity I sent it to
your sanity it's just the promo for some
reason you just sent you a promo to look
at the arms in that picture my mother
tell me where the kid it's a jokey
medium Josh wolf calm boom those arms
are [ __ ] killing that dude yeah man
it's like a man Josh wolf thanks for
having yeah this is fine kid we're out